something in common with your goals and
maybe if they get hit or not you know
uh oh we have F4 oh sapnap busting out a
Gambit look at this E5
I may or may not have had something to
do with this
um why are you teaching everybody the
gambits well I told him that listen
daily dose likes to play a bird and in
the bird there's a lot of these lines
where you can get a big attack you can
take but the bishop and the king is
going to be open but daily dose is solid
he's not taking everything he's just
you know responding there we go now
hopefully sapnap doesn't rush because
Knight takes obviously there's Queen
here but there is Pawn to G3 so you
don't but oh Bishop D look at that
beautiful he is developing his pieces
even though he gave up a pawn a pawn
doesn't mean as it as much as it does at
our level so I think sacrificing getting
the development is easily worth it
absolutely now black black is still
totally fine here because White's King
is a little bit weak so you can play
moves like Bishop here to try to remove
the Knight so you could put your queen
on the H4 Square uh there's also crazy
stuff like G5 G4 you could actually do
anything oh snap that is just going for
the kill oh my goodness what I mean you
did say it's made it's made Bishop G3 is
just checking
no it's mayhe oh my goodness zapdam is a
genius
does he see it
no he's hovering over the g-pawn he's
hovering over the g-pawn oh snap them
it's all gone so well it's perfect the
opening went so well Bishop G3 is mate
can we tune in
oh my goodness
does not seem like it's gonna be so easy
it's on the it's just right there he's
always said he's bad at puzzles when
they're live in games it's the only
check
wait
it's Checkmate oh
my God yes
right
oh I think daily dose has also seen it
check me
oh my holy
I need to see that it's a clip
wow
oh my goodness he slowed down he was
just about to go G5 G4 I'm not even
going to analyze sapnap takes a one to
nothing lead in five minutes of play
time
yeah daily dope and this is your daily
dose of blunders he is looking into the
camera
he laughed he seems to be